>> Sean: AS MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT
CONTINUES, REMEMBER MARK LEVIN
LAST SUMMER EXPLAINING THE DOJ
POLICY THAT SAID THE SITTING
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE MEDIA
FORGETS.
>> IT IS THE POSITION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND 1973
MEMRAPPEDUM UNDER THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU MUST NOT AND CANNOT INDICT
A SITTING PRESIDENT, NOT THAT
THIS PRESIDENT WOULD BE.
AS A MATTER OF CONSTITUTIONAL
INTERPRETATION.
44 YEARS THAT IS THE POSITION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE HAVE HAD LAW PROFESSOR AND
HOMELESS PEOPLE ALL OVER TV AND
TALKING ABOUT OBSTRUCTION.
MEDIA TYPES TALKING ABOUT IT.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THE OFFICIAL POSITION OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WE DON'T
CHARGE A SITTING PRESIDENT WITH
A CRIME.
>> Sean: MARK REITERATED THAT
POINT A FEW WEEKS AGO.
>> A SITTING PRESIDENT'S
IMMUNITY TO INDICTMENT AND
PROSECUTION THAT WOULD
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY UNDERMINE THE
ASSIGNED FUNCTION.
PAGE AFTER PAGE SAYING A SITTING
UNITED STATES
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE INDICTED.
DID THEY ISSUE ANOTHER MEMO IN
NIXON AND CLINTON.
NO.
>> AND THE HOST OF CRTV LEVIN
TV.
NUMBER ONE SHOW SUNDAY NIGHT
RIGHT HERE ON THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL AND I CALL HIM THE GREAT
ONE.
MARK, I WANTED TO PLAY THAT
AGAIN, AS USUAL ON LEGAL MATTERS
YOU ARE AHEAD OF THE CURVE AND
A CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY AND
OUR LAZY OVERPAID JOURNALIST ARE
WRONG 99 PERCENT OF THE TIME.
I WANT YOU TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN THIS.
>> THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SPEAKING AND THE
POSITION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT BEEN AMENDED
SINCE OCTOBER 16TH, 200.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF SECOND TIER
SLIP AND FALL LAWYERS ALL OVER
TVP SPEWING THINGS THAT DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTITUTION AND
HAVE NOT STUDIED THE CASES, I
HAVE.
FIRST OF ALL THE OPINION SAID
GRAND JURY AND PROSECUTORS
CANNOT SUPPLANT CONGRESS.
ONLY WAY TO REMOVE A SITTING
PRESIDENT IS IMPEACHMENT.
THEY CANNOT DISABLE OR HAM
STRING A PRESIDENCY WHICH IS
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO.
A PROSECUTOR CANNOT TWEAK THE
23'D AMENDMENT.
HE CAN'T STEP IN ANY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WERE
DISCUSSED.
A PRESIDENT CAN'T PROPERLY
DEFEND HIMSELF WHEN HE HAS TIME
TO SPEND ON OFFICIAL DUTIES.
UNLIKE SO MANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS SO UNIQUE
IN OUR CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM IT
IS DAMAGING TO HIM, BECAUSE HE
CAN'T FOCUS ON HIS DEFENSE WHICH
IS DIFFERENT ON CIVIL LIT GAGDZ
AND CAN'T FOCUS ON THE NATION'S
SECURITY AND WELL-BEING.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T FUNCTION
WITH THESE KINDS OF BURDEN.
AND HE CAN'T BE INDICTED AS
A SITTING PRESIDENT.
PERIOD.
PRESIDENTS HAVE RECEIVED
SUBPOENAS BEFORE.
TELL ME, TELL ME ONE WHO HAS
BEEN BEFORE A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY.
KEN STARR'S TEAM SUBPEONA BILL
CLINTON NOT SO MUCH FOR THE SEX
OF THE INTERN, BUT LYING ABOUT
LITIGATION THAT WAS TAKING
PLACE.
AND HE DECIDED TO DO A VIDEO.
HERE IS MY ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE DIDN'T SEEK IT AND TO HIS
LAWYERS.
FOCUS.
YOU ARE MAKING THIS TOO
COMPLICATED.
THE CONSTITUTION IS ON THE SIDE
OF THE PRESIDENT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
DECISION IS ON THE SIDE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HISTORICAL PRECEDENT IS ON THE
SIDE OF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
STOP LISTENING TO ALL OF THE
BABBLING AND PLEADING THE FIFTH
AND SITTING DOWN WITH A SUBPENE
A. AND I WOULD SAY TO MR.
MUELLER.
PRESENT US WITH AN EXPLANATION
OF YOUR DEFIANCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE POLICY
WHICH YOU ARE REQUIRED TO FOLLOW
AS AN EMPLOYEE OF THE DEPARTMENT
MUCH JUSTICE AND MOREOVER WE
WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT IS
THAT YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN
BURDEN A PRESIDENT LIKE THIS
WHILE HE'S IN OFFICE.
AND WHILE I AM AT IT.
A FEW REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
ARE CONFUSED AND VOTED TO
PROTECT MR. MUELLER THAN THE
PRESIDENT AND THE CONSTITUTION,
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THEY SEEM TO THINK THAT THEY
HAVE THE POWER EVEN TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT WHO HE CAN HIRE AND
FIRE.
PART OF THE PROBLEM OF THE
PRESIDENT HE IS DEALING WITH
IGNOREAMMOUS IN AND OUT OF HIS
PARTY AND SOME CRESSED UP AS
LAWYERS.
I WOULD MAKE MUELLER AND HIS
BAND OF DEMOCRAT PROSECUTORS
MAKE IT ALL THE WAY TO THE COURT
COURT AND IF THEY TRY TO
SUBPEONA TO APPEAR BEFORE
A FEDERAL GRAND JURY AND MAKE
THE CASE AGAINST THE SUPREME
COURT PRECEDENT AND AGAINST THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND IF IT TAKES SIX MONTHS, SIX
YEARS, BY GOD IT TAKES SIX
YEARS, WE ARE NOT JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT WHICH WOULD
BE ENOUGH.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PROTECTING
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY AND
SEPARATION OF POWERS AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT 49 AREAS WAS